this fall Marvel games and Insomniac are
set to bring Spider-Man 2 exclusively to
PlayStation 5. sounds like you guys are
a little hyped to tell us more is Brian
into Heart game director at Insomniac
Brian thanks for coming by I know you
guys are deep in development first of
all looks like we have some uh fancy art
behind us this is this the Box this is
the boxer you know this is it here it is
I mean
has two on the box for a reason because
this game features two Spider-Mans so
we're really excited about it absolutely
uh Peter and Miles uh we're so excited
about this um you know experience that
you guys are doing with these sort of
two characters uh we saw some great
Gameplay at the PlayStation showcase but
I want to talk about the two
villains I think in the game there may
be more there are more there are more
out there two main ones but uh we have
some new art to show of uh we obviously
Craven we got the reveal at the
PlayStation event so tell us a bit about
uh him and how he says Craven's very
different from any character we've done
he's not you know he's not powered by
magic or you know Tech he's just the
best hunter in the world and he's coming
to New York for his greatest hunt and
what's better than all of the Marvel
characters that live in New York City so
Peter miles and others he's on the hunt
and others yes but at Venom also
obviously uh you know symbiote is a part
of this whole story as we saw in the
gameplay oh there you go
good reaction to the art uh I'm glad
you're happy I don't know how much
you're going to tell us about then is
this uh can you tell is this is an
Osborne Venom okay tell us what's the
origin of Eddie Brock Venom or it is not
Eddie Brock okay it is not it is not
Eddie Brock okay
um our goal was to tell an original
story something you haven't seen in the
comics of the movies yet obviously wow
we love venom for a reason yeah all
those things you love about the
character are going to be there but how
the story plays out
who is Venom you have to play the game
to see how it goes yeah wow okay that's
there's a bit of a tease now obviously
the the Symbiote is a big part of the
gameplay and and one of the things like
we were all struck with the footage that
you showed at the PlayStation showcase
was uh you know how that is going to
really impact the gameplay when you're
playing as you know Peter so tell us a
bit about that and how you know the
gameplay is going to be dramatically
different yeah I mean I think you saw in
just the the raw power the strength and
even the transformation of of Peter's
moves in that in that in that gameplay
reveal you know he's you know we call
him the acrobatic improviser him and
miles but you can tell there's a lot
more strength a lot more raw power
aggression which you saw both in the
moves and how Peter talks so yeah it's
not just what happens in Game plates
what happens how the story plays out
interesting so how it affects him as
well yeah I mean you saw some of that
and there's much more of that Journey
when you play the game and I know the
the journey is also more expansive
you've got Queens Brooklyn so even more
of sort of yeah I mean the city has
pretty much doubled in size so it's
meant it's Manhattan Queens Brooklyn and
then being able to use the web links to
Traverse at speeds way faster than they
were before
um is really awesome hugely ambitious
game you guys have been building uh over
the past few years we saw at the um the
PlayStation event uh it said at the end
fall
2023 and I think you know we're like
getting close to that are you guys
feeling confident that gonna make it
this fall
you know Jeff I know you like exclusives
yes
and I can promise you we are very
confident what we're going to tell you
right now oh yeah okay yeah let's take a
look
nail in it October 20th Spider-Man 2
exclusively for PlayStation 5. got it
awesome well Brian thanks so much for
stopping by I know you got a lot of work
to do wrapping up the game but we'll
check it out in October thanks Brian
[Applause]